La volta al Montapeu, dia 312. Avui sí, pugem al camp base del Racapoixi.
Avui excursió més sèria que ahir, i això es nota perquè el guia, en comptes d'anar en xancletes, va amb calçat adequat.
I és que són 1.400 metres de desnivell positiu. Mira, ja em falta de l'aigua.
Han 8 quilòmetres, és a dir, la pujada serà bastant contundent.
I la idea és acampar dalt, per fi. Per fi acampem a Pakistan.
No som els únics turistes, veig que hi ha un altre grup. Hi ha un noi amb una motxilla pepina,
però crec que sí que sóc l'únic que porta material d'acampar de sobre, perquè allà dalt te'l lloguen.
Si tu vols acampar, doncs això, et lloguen la tenda, el sac i tot plegat.
A mi, com no en cal, doncs porto el meu. Això sí, la pujada serà més complicada, va.
Mireu el congost, que estret que es fa i quines aigües braves que hi ha aquí, eh?
Bé, aquí hi ha un pont, homenatge a un muntanyer austríac que va perdre la vida intentant pujar el Raca Poixi el 1985.
I després també el primer checkpoint on ens ha fet pagar l'entrada al parc, voldríem dir,
encara que no es parla de la vida.
És un parc natural, 500 rupis, que són un euro i mig.
Home, comparat amb altres parcs naturals que ens han fotut una clavada en aquest viatge,
aquest em sembla un preu molt raonable.
Encara que, mira, això de pagar per anar a la muntanya, doncs mai ho acabaria d'entendre, eh?
Però bueno, en fi, ja s'han de guanyar la vida d'alguna manera.
És un parc natural, 500 rupis, que ens ha fet pagar l'entrada al parc, voldríem dir, aquest em sembla un preu molt raonable.
Normalment, quan vas en grup, encara que sigui un grup petit, així de tres,
vas més tranqui, no? No vas tan ràpid, tal, però no, no, no.
Portem un ritme infernal.
I això és el més lent.
Alguns diuen que després ja t'entens caminant.
Suposo que la meva capacitat cardiovascular ha muntat a saco, però...
Jo crec que no.
Jo crec que no, perquè...
Ja ho he dit alguna vegada, no faig gaires pujades.
Vaig sobretot en pla.
Bueno, hi ha núvols, de moment aguanta el temps, no hi ha vent,
i això ajuda a no estar, que no ens estiguem torrant amb el sol.
Però a la vegada, les imatges, doncs, clar, amb aquesta llum no queda tan bé.
Però per caminar s'agraeix bastant.
Havíem pujat avui en comptes d'ahir, recordeu, perquè ahir havia de ploure,
que al final no va ploure, i avui no.
I a l'altra banda de la vall, que hi ha uns núvols molt lletjos,
no esperen d'escoltar trons.
No sé, escolta ara.
Bueno...
Que es quedi ja.
Que no vingui cap aquí, sisplau.
Ja seria mala sort, eh?
Bueno, m'ha arribat aquí una espècie de poblet.
Mireu, portem 4,6 quilòmetres i...
gairebé 600 metres d'esnivell positiu.
Per tant, en horitzontal portem la meitat,
però en vertical encara queden 900 metres d'esnivell positiu.
Això vol dir que serà una pujada intensa.
Però bueno, tu, no tenim pressa, és que són les 11, eh?
Si arribéssim ja a la 1 estaríem allà superavorrits, home.
Vaig a descansar una estona aquí assegut a aquest espècie de prat.
Parada per fer un te.
Aquí a Pakistan el te normalment me l'han posat sempre amb llet.
Però aquest no, aquest és especialment...
té sense...
sense aquest.
Bueno, ara està massa calent.
Fet del senyor aquest que viu aquí,
tipus, una setmana, seguida,
i després torna a casa i torna aquí,
perquè està, doncs, cuidant les...
vaques, cabres, caça, també.
Aquí hi ha una escopeta.
A les 12 i 10 m'ha arribat aquí una zona,
això no és el campament base, eh?
Però aquí són ja totes les tendes, hi ha un munt de tendes aquí.
Suposo que deuen ser seves, no deuen ser de campistes...
que nosaltres.
Simplement les joguen.
Està guapo aquest lloc, eh?
No és obert per la llum aquesta, eh?
Però mola, bueno...
Estic cansat.
Es diu Camping Site Hapakun
i el porta la mateixa gent
que el porta a l'hotel on he estat avui.
O sigui, aquestes dues passades nits.
I... i res.
Aquí farem una sentada.
Llavors, bueno...
Hello!
Sí, aquí pots venir, pujar,
quedar-te a dormir
i visitar el camp base i després tornar a baixar.
Estava estant ben muntada la cosa aquesta, eh?
Si ets una persona que necessita una mica més d'infraestructura, ajuda,
un lavabo, una tenda, refugi...
Al final sembla que sí que he empringat una mica
perquè m'han dit que està plovent.
Bueno.
Bueno, de moment són quatre gotes.
Això que ens ha agafat aquí, mireu.
Tinga, tenim aquí aquesta espècie de tenda llurta
i aquí estan fent el dinar.
Oh, no!
Ostres, quin desastre.
Sóc un desastre, mira.
No ha plogut.
I et tira tot el te, tu.
Quin desastre.
Bueno, tu aquí està el dinar.
No ha plogut.
Ostres, tu acabo de sortir de la tenda
la tenda per fer un pipí
i mireu, ha acabat de ploure
i mireu quin cel blau espectacular
Home, hi hauré
que sí que fem el camp base
amb aquestes condicions
Genial, tu has sortit al sol
És molt ràndom el temps a la muntanya
especialment muntanyes tan altes
Ara sí, comencem
l'ascens fins al camp base, no sé què ha passat
que hem passat de ser 3 a
6 o 7
No sé, va, i a tu
Està bé, està bé
Està bé
A veure
que a la vista després d'aquest zigzag diuen que és brutal
Uau
Never seen
something like that before, I think
And I've seen a lot of glaciers
but not like this
Uau
It's like knives
Crec que haurien d'haver pujat abans, eh?
Ho veuríem amb més sol
ara està en ombra
També està en vell a baix
amb els valls aquests
al menjar, al pet
L'altra muntanya la que es veu aquí a l'esquerra és el...
a l'esquerra és el d'Iran, crec,
i el Recapbosi té una mica de núvols.
Bueno, estem a prop, eh?
Mitja horeta, crec, o menys.
Brutal, brutal, brutal.
M'havien dit, eh?, molta gent, que era increïble, però...
que no ho podia perdre, que no ho podia perdre,
però no pensava que fos tant, eh?
És que havia vist jo glaceres,
tipus les de la muntanya, no?
Les que has de mirar,
com mires a dalt.
Però així, d'aquesta manera,
tipus, a baix...
Pfff...
Brutal.
I aquí hi ha una paperera,
que m'encanta,
amb dues enganxines del Schalke 04, tu.
Que ets alemany.
T'ha anat tot arreu.
I aquí hi ha un plat.
Tu també.
Com le veis?
I el que veig aquí.
Que som.
Vas a veure un pal.
¿Cómo te veig?
¿Cómo te veis?
Muy bien.
¿
Eh?
Sant Nerisma aquí, al Base Camp, al camp base del Diran, també a Gilgit, hi ha altres llocs, qualsevol excursió, Escardú, Junze, qualsevol lloc d'aquesta zona, amb el Camil ho podeu fer.
15 anys, la primera vegada que vinc aquí, 15 anys, ara 25 anys.
25 anys, uau, ok, ok, amazing. Ara, bueno, per res, muntem la tenda abans que se'n vagi el sol, però bueno, 4 i mitja.
Ja estic acampat allà baix i ara he posat aquí aquesta zona que és com una cresta i pots veure el camp base que està aquí darrere i aquí davant,
un altre cop la glacera aquesta, amb la muntanya aquesta que es deia Diràs, crec, o Diran, Diran, i el Recapuixi darrere.
Que Recapuixi vol dir mur de gel, però no és com li diuen ells, els locals. Els locals li diuen d'una altra manera, que és aquesta, que la tinc a punt d'anar, però no me'n recordo,
i aquesta manera dels locals vol dir dues muntanyes.
Sí, perquè refereix a...
Fixa, els dos pics, el Diran i el Recapuixi.
Bueno, moltes gràcies a tots els que m'heu insistit que vingués aquí, perquè si no no hagués vingut, perquè com venien ahir i avui aquests dos dies de pluja,
potser hagués dit, bé, saps, passo, passo perquè continuo caminant i ja està, saps, perquè aquí en realitat estaré 3 dies sense, saps, sense avançar,
però ha valgut la pena, ha valgut la pena 100%. A veure com passo aquesta nit, perquè...
Fa bastanta res, que aquí no sé si es nota que em costa parlar del fred.
Bueno, no sé, a vegades el teu look pot equivocar-se, però deia que podria fer mínimes de dos, quatre.
Bueno, el mussà que aguanta amb menys dos, per tant, crec que estarem bé.
I si veniu, doncs és un luxe venir amb aquest rotllo, podeu venir pel vostre compte, però que us facin el dinar, el sopar, l'esmorzar, és una passada, i no és car, eh, de molla us diré com m'ha costat.
Jo diria que avui m'he engreixat més que he cremat calories, saps, he guanyat més calories de les que he cremat, perquè m'han donat moltíssim menjar.
Última vista en aquesta glacera.
Dormirem, superem, i no s'acaba aquí el vídeo, perquè demà, en el mateix vídeo, us ensenyaré també la sortida del sol, i així, d'aquesta manera, ho tancarem.
Mira, 3, 2, 1...
Dia 313.
Pam!
Mira, tio, és que mira el mur de gel, eh.
A mi m'han explicat que aquesta muntanya la gent la puja per una altra cara.
Que per aquesta cara no es puja des dels anys 90, des de fa més de 30 anys.
Bueno, molt maco, eh.
Encara que estigui contraiu...
Ahir a la nit s'escoltaven algunes llavissades.
Ens van dir, això que escolta és una llavissada.
Vam fer un foc ahir.
Ha sigut una nit freda, sí, però vaig dormir amb el cos calent perquè vam fer un foc, cosa que, com a pixapí, m'encanta.
A més, a Catalunya és que està prohibit fer foc a tot arreu, no? Llavors, és una cosa poc habitual.
Genial, tu, ara anem a esmorzar, i espero que no vulguin entretenir-se molt, perquè jo vull baixar i continuar el meu camí.
Fins demà!
Doncs ja està. Tornem a Sevall, a Mirapint, i aquí s'acaba el vídeo d'avui.
Jo el que faré ara serà tornar a la carretera, allà tornare a engegar el darrere,
i seguiré el meu camí de la volta amb una peu,
però això ja no ho gravaré.
I, de fet, demà no hi haurà vídeo,
demà dia de descans, i tornem demà passat.
Ha sigut una excursió molt guai,
molt recomanable.
Us recomano a tots que veniu a Pakistan
i que veniu a fer el Raka Puchi.
Aquí us poso el que m'he gastat
comptant les dues nits en aquest hotel,
tots els àpats, tots els dinars, esmorzars, bla, bla, bla,
el guiatge amb el camí, bla, bla, bla.
M'ha costat això.
I res, bon cap de setmana. Passeu.